qu'est ce que tu as fait pour les
vacances dernier
je suis parti
voix pour les faibles a été en israël
avec ta mère je crois qu'on a pensé
j'ai dit un truc
à faire franchement est ce que j'appelle
mais c'est que
en mars c'est la sécurité du mien pour
partir cet été
c'était super frier stands et les
bagages t c'est là que désirs des jeunes
ont cassé
[Musique]
ces normes par contre ce que j'ai pas
aimé ce que j'étais à jérusalem est
[Musique]
ah oui il peut répondre vacances
private jean partie visible parce que
j'étais là tu donc en fait sur sur 12
jours de vacances j'en ai pris j'ai pris
cinq jours de soleil je vois ça comme en
l'avenir dans l'état palestinien
dire carrément politique zéro je connais
rien
pascal et ça c'est la victoire
c'est quand même un ton pays enfin mon
pays c'est pas ton pays mais c'est quand
même un pays important
donne tout son sens à cette issue
politique je me suis occupée vous n'êtes
pas je peux comprendre aussi que la
palestine ça ne m'intéresse pas non j'ai
pas cette question c'est qui ça
m'intéresse je m'occupe à quoi je veux
dire plein de trucs à la pensée car la
politique est tous à ses branches pas tu
ferais quoi six ans s'étaient pas
rencontrés
tu travailleras les compères dans la
sphère des fruits et légumes à rungis
ouais je pense parce que c'est une super
bonne ambiance avant et
les camions sympa
c'est un travail dur
dur si on voit ça les punks ou
nous voilà quoi je me suis sympa
et dis moi et tu me poses ça mais toi
que tu ferais qu'histoire et phedra ben
moi je voulais faire du cinéma tu crois
qu'on a apporté quoi la chanson
française
pour l'instant ouais
dire un truc je vous la pose souvent des
questions mais je pense que
on a apporté peut-être
des souvenirs aux jeunes les souvenirs
de vacances aux jeunes
on a apporté peut-être un peu inquiété
dans les familles
et c'est pas fini est ce que tu crois
que ça nous a vachement étais tu
t'appelles david marouani
c'est une très bonne question
ballon je pense ma réponse mais tu peux
penser dans la pensée
je pense que
c'est difficile quand vous avez du
métier bon c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que
quand
le producteur a emmené le disque aux
médias tout le monde savait que je
m'appelle david marouani donc dans un
sens c'était bien dans un sens c'était
pas bien parce que le piston serait
jamais dit moi est ce que tu penses
sincèrement
3d yeux dirais très franchement est ce
que tu penses qu'on va continuer à
sortir au sommaire way you choses à se
dire moi je nous vois mais je pense que
si on doive ensemble si un jour ça
marche plus et que on a plus aucun
disque et que
l'entente n'est plus la même il faudra
songer à
se diversifier mais pour l'instant tout
va bien
on va essayer de continuer
enfoncer le clou
qu'est-ce qui t'énerve le plus chez moi
qu'est ce que tu vas pas
attention franchement toujours chaud
franchement mais jean kaka tribunal j'ai
jugé tout ça sert move resserrement
franchement c'est une question difficile
la vérité
la vérité ce qui m'énerve le plus c'est
c'est quand même c'est difficile à dire
mais il faut que je me dise puisqu'on
est là pour lui c'est parfois pour
manque de sérieux des choses très
importantes
est-ce qu'il tenait chez moi
jpt sincèrement ça la caméra les caméras
et la meilleure chez david souvent c'est
parfois il est un petit peu égoïste et
la femme ne sait pas c'est pas faire la
part des choses
c'est vrai c'est un garçon très gentil
j'aime beaucoup c'est vrai que c'est
vrai ce que tu dis je sais que je suis
égoïste des fois et ça c'est bien c'est
vrai mais moi je le fais antoine schneck
3 1
car toi en rupture ne
embêté quand bt oui en bts que tu as
est-ce que tu avais les nuls
dernièrement
sur l'est le clip cola fait qu'ils ont
changé en faisant qu'est-ce que tu vends
pour les vacances qu'est ce que t'en es
ce que tu penses que ça génial pour ça
génial parce que parce que je suis perdu
un fake c'est marrant et que c'est pas
le méchant du tout donc ça marche mieux
avec les filles depuis qu'on a quatre
enfants
ça marche bien
faut savoir trouver la fille qui
qui tu aimes bien parce que tu chantes
outils tels bien parce que
parce que c'est toi c'est toujours c'est
toujours problème c'est difficile mais
elle s'est récemment juillet ça marche
ça marche et bien déjà mais là ça marche
plus c'est un style marché beaucoup
donc je sais pas qui sera pas aussi
enfin ça marche bien
on va dire ça marche pas tout mais il
faut que
savoir faire la part des choses toujours
par la musique fait la musique et y
voilà les corrections de ne rien rater
de in a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux